MAYA BEN ARI: Hello,
everyone, and welcome
to Behind the Scenes-- What's
New in Android Accessibility.
My name is Maya Ben Ari.
I'm a product manager on
Android accessibility.
And with me today are
a couple of people
from the accessibility team.
We're going to show you
a couple of new features,
a couple of new demos,
and a unique look
of behind the scene.
So this is our agenda for today.
We'll give a brief overview
about accessibility.
We'll talk about what's new
in accessibility in Android N.
We'll talk about the
Gesture Dispatch API
and show a couple
of very cool demos.
Also, we'll look through Voice
Access, a new accessibility
service.
And then we'll give a brief
look at behind the scene
in UX research.
So let's start.
What is accessibility?
Accessibility is about
creating products
that are usable by
everyone, including people
with disabilities, such
as motor impairment
or visual impairment.
But I'd like to
rephrase this definition
as slightly different.
And I would say
that accessibility
is about challenging
the assumptions we
make about our users.
For example, can the
user see the device
or distinguish between colors?
Can he or she touch the
device or hear back the sound
that the device is producing?
And can the user speak
back to the device?
Now, this is not a small number.
20% of the US population will
have some sort of a disability
during their lifetime,
according to the US Census.
But it's not only that.
Challenging the assumption
can benefit all the users.
Why?
Because some of the
technologies that
were developed in the past, such
as speech recognition or word
prediction, started as
technologies for users
with accessibility needs.
But this is not all.
We are all the accessibility
users sometime.
This is called
situational disability.
When we drive our car, we
cannot look at our phone.
When we are in a
noisy environment,
we cannot hear the
sound of the device,
and we cannot speak
back to the device.
And when we carry heavy
bags from the supermarket,
we cannot touch the device.
So we want to design
an inclusive experience
for all users, regardless
of what restriction the user
might have.
Now, let me briefly mention
some accessibility services
and features available
on the platform today.
So first, what is an
accessibility service?
This is a long-running
privilege service
that changes the interaction
model with a device in one
of two ways.
One, it can change the way the
user interacts with a device,
or it can change
the way that content
is presented to the user.
Now, the first
accessibility service
we have on the device
today is TalkBack.
TalkBack is targeted for
people with vision impairment,
or blind.
And it's basically
a screen reader.
Now, the user can interact with
the device using touch gesture,
and content is presented,
spoken to the user
through text-to-speech.
The second accessibility
service is BrailleBack.
So can we switch to the demo?
So BrailleBack is similar to
TalkBack, just in this case,
the user can interrupt
with something
which is called a
Braille-refreshable display.
The user can type
through these keys,
or interrupt with this joystick.
And then the
content is presented
using Braille in
those Braille cells,
with the dots
raising and lowering.
The next service
is Switch Access.
Switch Access is targeted
for a motor-impaired user
who has trouble interacting
with a touch display.
In this case, we
have something which
is called adaptive switch.
This adaptive switch
has two buttons.
And the user can configure
one button as Next,
and one button as Select.
And using only
these two buttons,
the user can interact
with the device.
Note that the switch can be
with more or less the buttons.
Can we switch back
to the slides?
And the last accessibility
service is Voice Access.
In Voice Access, the user can
preform low-level interaction
on the device using
only his voice.
This is a new service that
we originally launched.
And Patrick and Scott, from
the accessibility group,
will soon tell us
more about this one.
We also have a couple of
accessibility features
already baked into
the platform--
for example, large text,
magnification gestures,
coloring version or color
correction for people
with light sensitivity
or who are colorblind,
high-contrast text,
and caption support.
In the next section,
we're going to dive
into the latest and
greatest feature
for accessibility in Android.
And we have a lot of
very exciting things
to share with you.
The first one is vision
setting on the Welcome screen.
This will enable
visually impaired users
to independently
set up their device.
Now can we switch
please to the demo?
Focus.
OK.
So this is the main screen,
the Welcome screen on Android.
And here at the bottom,
we have vision settings
that flash every 10 seconds.
4, 3, here you go.
So if I tap on that, I am
presented a couple of options.
I have magnification gesture,
phone size, display size,
TalkBack.
So for example, I can select
magnification gestures,
and then I can triple-tap,
and I can increase the size
and magnify the UI.
Now, another option that I want
to highlight is display size.
This is a new feature
launched in Android N.
So if this is the
regular screen size,
I can increase the size of
the overall UI to be bigger.
Now, the nice thing
about all those settings
is that whatever
settings I'm selecting,
it's going to be reflected both
through all the Welcome screen,
but also as the user setting
throughout the device.
Back to the slides.
Another cool feature
is mono audio support.
This one is intended
for people who
have hearing loss in one ear.
And this enables them to
listen to mono audio stream.
And we do that by combining
the left and right channels
into a single mono audio stream.
And we also have a couple
of new features in TalkBack,
including improved tutorial
clarity, improved gesture
detection to work better across
different devices and hardware.
And also, we added a new API
for accessibility service
to turn themselves off.
So if the user accidentally
turns on TalkBack
on the Welcome screen, they
can easily turn it off.
Now, the next section is about
the gesture dispatch API.
And this is something that I'm
personally very excited about,
because now we will allow app
developers to build services
such as point scanning, face
tracker, and eye tracker.
So for the next one,
I'd like to invite
Anna, an engineer on
the accessibility team,
to demo the APIs.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA GALUSZA: Thanks, Maya.
I'm Anna, and I'll tell you
about the new gesture dispatch
API that lets accessibility
services mimic
touching the screen.
First of all, what's a touch?
Well, it has three parts--
placing a finger on the screen,
drawing a path or gesture,
and lifting the finger.
The new API lets you,
as the developer,
specify that middle
portion, the path taken
by an imaginary
finger or fingers.
Now, why is this important
for accessibility?
Let's take a look
at Switch Access,
an accessibility service
that does not assume
that you can touch the screen.
Rather, it lets you use a
switch or a set of switches
to move-highlight
across actionable views
and select the currently
highlighted view.
Now, this leaves off
some functionality
when you don't want to
interact with the entire view,
but rather a small part of it.
The example that I'll be using
is Google Maps, specifically
the maps area, which
supports complex gestures--
things like zooming in and out
and padding the visible area.
So with this new
gesture dispatch API,
we can add point scanning
to Switch Access,
and that lets us perform
these complex gestures.
So let's take a look at how we
can use one switch to operate
Google Maps.
We'll start in the Maps app.
And you'll notice here I have
a switch already connected
to my device.
I like to get walking
directions to the three
buildings just west of here.
I don't quite remember
what they're called.
But fortunately, once we
make a selection on the map,
we can get directions that way.
So here it seems like
I don't see those three
buildings on the map, so I'll
have to pan to get to see them.
I'll start point scanning
by pressing the switch.
And the first thing
I'll do now is select
where I want to
perform that gesture.
First the y-coordinate,
then the x-coordinate.
And here I'll choose
to swipe right.
So now at the lower left,
we see the three buildings
that I'd like to walk to.
I'm going to place a pin
there by long-pressing.
So again, I'll start by choosing
the location first, starting
with the y-coordinate again,
and then the x-coordinate.
And here I'll choose long-press
from the Actions menu.
This gives me a
button at the bottom
of the screen asking whether
I'd like walking directions.
As that's exactly
what I'll want,
I'm going to select that button.
So again, I'll choose
the location first.
And here I'll choose Select.
And here we are--
directions to the point
we just chose from the
map using just one switch.
I'll hand the mike
back to Maya now,
who will tell you about
another really cool application
of the gesture dispatch API.
[APPLAUSE]
MAYA BEN ARI: Thank
you, Anna, for the demo.
And the next demo is an
extremely exciting one
for a head tracker, using
the dispatch gesture API,
by a company called
Sesame Enable.
Sesame Enable is
an Israeli company
that was co-founded
by two people--
Oded, who is a
computer vision expert;
and Giora, who is a
high-current engineer who
became quadriplegic due
to spinal cord injury.
Now, Sesame Enable
utilizes the front camera
of the device to
track head movements
and move a mouse cursor.
Now, I'd like to invite
Vladi, the head of development
from Sesame Enable, onto the
stage to demo the technology.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey, Vladi.
How are you doing?
VLADI: Great, great, great.
MAYA BEN ARI: Ready for this?
So the first thing that Vladi
will do is he will-- can
we move to the demo?
The first thing that Vladi
will do is enable the service.
Now, this can be
done through voice.
But because of the
acoustics here, Vladi
will just tap on the
Sesame Enable notification.
Now, the service will
calibrate Vladi's face.
After it locks it down, Vladi
can control a mouse cursor
using only his head.
Now, if Vladi would like to tap
on something, he just dwells.
And he can tap.
Now, once Vladi is into his
email, he can swipe up or down.
I think we're a little
bit excited. [LAUGHS]
VLADI: Sorry.
MAYA BEN ARI: It's OK.
It's OK.
Would you like me to help you?
Do you want me to help you?
VLADI: You can try it.
MAYA BEN ARI: Let's try it out.
So the first thing
that I'm going to do--
and we didn't reverse it, so I'm
going to try to help here-- I'm
going to calibrate my face.
OK.
Now I can control
the mouse cursor.
It's a little bit hard here,
because the overall stage
is shaky.
It is hard.
Yeah, it's hard to calibrate.
The overall stage is
shaky, and it's hard to do.
But this is what this
demo is all about.
So in general, after we
move the mouse cursor,
we can also, like,
lock the sensor.
This is by looking right.
Yeah.
VLADI: Do you want
me to try again?
MAYA BEN ARI: Yeah, sure.
Try again.
Just go to Candy Crush.
Yeah.
Sorry.
So in general, this demo is
about how to control a mouse
cursor using the device.
It's a little bit hard
to do it on stage,
because the [INAUDIBLE]
stage is a little bit shaky.
That's right.
And--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So the thing is basically,
you can do everything
using a head tracker
on the device,
including tapping and
touching and swiping and also
downloading any app
from the Play Store
and basically interacting with
that app only using your face.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you want to try it out
in a little bit of a less
shaky stage, you are more
than welcome to come out
to Access & Empathy
sandbox to try it out.
And one last note about this API
is that while this API is very
powerful, it doesn't diminish
the need for an app developer
to make their accessible, such
as adding content labelling
or increasing touch target size.
Because while the API
allows you to interact
with different
elements on the screen,
it doesn't know which
element it interacts with.
So following every best practice
is still very important.
So thank you so much,
Vladi, for your help.
[APPLAUSE]
And with that, I
would like to hand it
off to Patrick and Scott
to talk about Voice Access.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK CLARY: Alrighty.
Thanks, Maya.
I'm Patrick Clary,
product manager
on accessibility at Google.
And with me is Scott
Newman, software engineer
on accessibility at Google.
And we're here, very
excited to talk to you
about a new accessibility
service for Android
called Voice Access.
And this is an
accessibility service
that is meant for users
with a motor impairment that
find it hard to use a touch
screen with their hands.
But before we talk about that,
I want to tell you about one
of our testers,
whose name is Andy.
Andy is a 65-year-old male
with essential tremor.
And for Andy, he
really likes to be
able to communicate
with friends and family
and send them pictures through
email and messages and updates.
And he generally
does this at home
on his desktop PC
utilizing an app
like Dragon
NaturallySpeaking, which
allows him to dictate by voice.
However, Andy would really like
to be able to do this on the go
from his mobile device.
But due to his tremor,
using a touch screen
is very problematic.
Now, if we take
a step back here,
we realize that Andy's
experience is not that unique.
In fact, there are millions
of people in the US
alone that have some
form of motor impairment
that impacts how they
can use a touch screen.
So this can range from
people with essential tremor,
like Andy, to people who have
Parkinson's, amputees, people
with arthritis, even people
with spinal cord injuries,
just to name a few.
Now, in addition
to that, there's
many more people
who have what we
call a situational disability,
like Maya mentioned before.
This could be a
temporary impairment
that affects their use of
a touch screen, something
like a broken hand or wrist.
Or maybe their
hands are occupied.
A common use case
we actually hear
is that someone
might be cooking,
and their hands are dirty.
They don't use their hands.
And they'd love to be able to
still control their device.
So this is really the motivation
we have for Voice Access.
And our goal with
Voice Access is
to provide someone this
complete control of their device
through use of
their voice alone.
In essence, we want
to be able to allow
users to click by voice.
Or, to put it in the words
of one of our testers,
"Use your voice and you're
able to access the world."
So you might be asking, how
does an accessibility service
like Voice Access differ
from a voice assistant
like Google Now or OK Google,
where you can say this hot word
and then perform a search query,
which is more conversational?
Or you can perform
a voice action,
like you can set a reminder,
you can create a calendar event?
An accessibility
service is different.
What we're looking for
is to empower people
to be able to use their device
and have full device control.
Now the high-level
voice assistant
is really lacking the
fine-grained commands
needed to do this.
So for example, I mentioned
Jeff likes to send messages
to friends and family.
So from his mobile device,
if he wanted to do this,
he might have to
open the camera app,
take a photo by
pressing a button.
Then open an app like Hangouts
by clicking on the icon,
scrolling and swiping to
the contact he wanted,
clicking on Attach the
Photo, and then tapping
on the text box, typing in
text, and then clicking Send.
So with Voice
Access, our goal is
for each of those touch actions
to enable a corresponding voice
command that allows
users to chain together
a series of these commands
to perform a complex task.
So to see it in real
life, I'll hand it over
to Scott, who will
give you guys a demo.
SCOTT NEWMAN: Thanks
a lot, Patrick.
So my name is Scott Newman.
I am a software engineer
on the accessibility team.
And I'm excited to give you
a demo of Voice Access today.
Before I go ahead
and get started,
I just wanted to mention that
as some of you may be aware,
speech recognition
demos can be fickle
in front of live audiences.
So if we run into any
issues, just bear with me,
and we'll get through them.
So with that, let's go
ahead and get started.
So I remember that Patrick
sent me a message a little bit
earlier.
And I'd like to read it,
but before I actually
read the message, I'm going to
go into Accessibility settings
and enable large text
so it's a little easier
for those people in
the back of the room
to see what's on the screen.
[TONE]
Open Settings.
Scroll to the bottom.
[TONE]
Tap Accessibility.
Tap Large Text.
[TONE]
Go Home.
Let's try one more time.
[TONE]
Go Home.
All right.
There we go.
So that's Voice
Access an action.
So what actually
happened right there?
So you may notice that there's
this persistent blue button
that appears on the top
right of the screen.
And so that's at Voice
Access activation button.
So from any screen, you
just press that button,
and then Voice Access
starts listening.
And then from
there, you can issue
commands to globally
navigate the device,
interact with individual
elements on the screen,
and basically control your
device entirely by voice.
So what I did there was I opened
the Settings app by saying,
open settings.
I said, scroll to the bottom to
actually scroll the screen down
as if I were performing a
traditional tap gesture.
Then I said, tap Accessibility
to tap the corresponding button
on the screen that was labeled
with the text accessibility.
And then I did the
exact same thing
to press the switch
labeled Large Text.
So this actually uses the
same accessibility APIs
that underlie the
other accessibility
services that we've seen so far,
like TalkBack or Switch Access.
So as long as you follow
accessibility development best
practices, your
apps should actually
work with Voice Access
right out of the box.
So with that, let's
actually see the message
that Patrick sent me.
[TONE]
Could we go back to cast?
Thanks.
[TONE]
Open Hangouts.
Patrick Clary.
[TONE]
Stop Voice Access.
Again, so I used Voice Access
to open the Hangouts app.
And then when I said,
Patrick Clary, it actually
found the clickable button
on the screen with text
that was labeled Patrick Clary
and then clicked that button
on my behalf.
So one other thing that
you may be noticing
is that there are
these numbers that
are drawn on the screen whenever
Voice Access is actively
listening.
And so what that is is
kind of a safety fallback.
So if you want to interact with
something on the screen that's
clickable or
scrollable, and there's
no text associated
with it-- let's say,
a clickable image--
then you can default
to just saying the number,
and it will flick that element
on your behalf.
So with that, I'm going to
respond to Patrick's message
and then send it.
[TONE]
Type, the party is at 7:00.
I actually notice
that I made a mistake.
The party is I think at
8:00 instead of 7:00,
so let me change really quickly.
[TONE]
Replace 7:00 with 8:00.
So in addition to
navigation, interacting
with individual
elements on the screen,
we actually offer a full suite
of text-editing commands.
And so that was just one of very
many that you can use to edit
text.
You can replace parts
of text with other text.
You can copy.
You can move elements around.
So it's just a really fast
way to actually interact
with whatever's on
the current screen.
And the Hangouts
app actually didn't
need to do anything special
to work with Voice Access.
It just works right
out of the box.
So what I'm going to do
now is send the message.
You'll notice that at the
bottom right of the screen
is this green Send button.
And there's no text
associated with it.
So in order to
click that button,
I'm going to reactivate
Voice Access,
and then I'm going to
say the number that's
associated with it that appears
right next to the button.
Then it's going to click that
button and send the message.
So let's go ahead and do that.
[TONE]
Tap 11.
Stop Voice Access.
Nope.
[TONE]
Undo.
Stop Voice Access.
[TONE]
So that's Voice Access for you.
So notice that you
can start Voice Access
by pressing this blue button.
Actually, if you want to do
it completely hands-free,
if you say the OK
Google command,
there's actually another
way that you can access it
completely hands-free by voice.
We offer a whole host
of activation methods
so you can choose what's
most efficient for you.
Similarly, you can
stop Voice Access
by saying, stop
voice access, or just
by touching the screen, which
is kind of a fail-safe option
to leave Voice Access quickly.
So that's what's Voice
Access in practice.
Can we go back to
the deck, please?
Thanks.
So let's hear from some
actual Voice Access users
about how it's
impacted their lives.
Roll the video, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Let's go, guys.
My name's Stephanie,
and I just finished
my master's in advertising.
I'm a C4/C5 split-level
quadriplegic.
I have no feeling
from my collarbone
down, so it is absolutely vital
that I'm able to use my voice.
OK, Google.
Start Voice Access.
-My name's Jeff, and I have
a neurological condition
called essential tremor.
It is incredibly difficult
to use my hands and fingers.
It is very easy for
me to use my voice.
OK, Google.
Start Voice Access.
-After using this product for
probably about 10 seconds,
I think I'm falling
in love with it.
Open camera.
You use your voice, and you're
able to access the world.
Shutter, share Hangouts,
Astrid Weber, Send.
-I cannot tell you how excited
I am about this product.
Open calendar, new.
When you don't have the ability
to use your fingers and hands--
family movie night-- it's
really all about voice.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT NEWMAN: So
that's Voice Access.
We're really excited
for you to try it out.
It's in open beta right now.
So if you come over to the
Access & Empathy sandbox here,
you could try it out yourself.
With that, I'm going
to hand it over
to Astrid and Jen, who are going
to talk about how you can use
UX research to improve the
quality of your product,
with Voice Access
as a case study.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
JEN DEVINS: Thank you, Scott.
Hi, my name is Jen,
and this is Astrid.
We are inclusive design
and researchers in Google,
and we wanted to
share with you today
a little bit about how UX
research influenced and drove
the design of Voice Access.
But first, what is UX research?
The general
definition is that it
focuses on understanding user
behaviors, needs, motivations
through observation
techniques, task analysis,
and other methodologies.
The key here is
that while we might
think we know what users
want, because maybe we
are users of our own product, or
maybe we are really close to it
and develop and design it,
it's critical to get out
there and get feedback
from external users
and understand their unique
perspectives, insights,
challenges, and pain points.
In fact, the products
that we demoed here today
all underwent many iterations
of design and development,
and all of which were inspired
and driven by UX research.
The process itself is
about a five-step process,
and it can be cyclical if
you want to keep refining.
The way it was applied
to Voice Access,
it was first looking at
what are the objectives
of the product as a whole.
One key objective
of Voice Access
was that they wanted to
ensure it was easy to use,
easy to learn how to
use right out of the box
in a hands-free manner.
And so from there, they
developed hypotheses.
OK.
So based on that objective, they
thought that contextual help
was the best way to allow
people to learn how to use
the product in the moment.
From there, they defined what
the best methodologies were
to use, conducted the research,
synthesized those findings,
and reported those back to the
team, which further iterated
on the design of the product.
So now Astrid is
going to take you
through the specific
methodologies used
and how those insights
actually impacted
the design of Voice Access.
ASTRID WEBER: Thank you, Jen.
I'm Astrid Weber.
I'm a UX researcher
working on Voice Access.
And I'd like to show you how
we accompanied the design
and development process with
a few research methodologies.
And I'd like to get started
with formative research.
Formative research is
if you go into the field
in order to understand
about your users
from their daily lives.
So you go and see
how they work, how
they lives their lives at home.
And we did that in particular
with users with severe motor
impairments, as
you've seen before
with the user in our video.
What we learned out there
is that at the moment,
there is no cohesive strategy
for people who cannot use
their hands in order to access
their mobile devices completely
hands-free.
After we knew that, we
went back and developed
the first prototype
of Voice Access.
As soon as we had something
that was testable, we test it.
And we did so with
internal testing.
Internal testing is probably
best known to tech companies,
because all you
need is yourself.
So all of us within the team
installed the application,
people outside the
team, and we tried
to use it in as
many circumstances
and contexts as possible.
What we found was a lot of bugs.
So we addressed those bugs,
we made the product better.
We iterated it until
we got to the point
that we felt the product is so
stable now that we can actually
put it in front of real users.
And that's what we did.
We ran usability studies.
Usability studies are when you
invite people to actually come
into your lab.
Those are people from the
core audience, so in our case,
people with severe motor
impairments, and they test it.
And you are in front of them.
You can see exactly
what they're doing.
And they're running through
a couple of tasks with you,
and you see the
limitations of the product.
You see where it's failing.
But you also see where people
are especially delighted.
And what you see actually in
the picture is one of our labs.
It's designed to
be very comfortable
and welcoming to our users.
And at the same
time, it has cameras
to capture audio and video,
so afterwards we can actually
go back into the data,
analyze, and see exactly how we
can improve the product.
Usability studies are great,
but they have their limitations.
And I think the
biggest limitation
is that it's a very
short period of time
that your user is
interacting with the product.
And it's in a lab environment,
so it's not the real life.
So we went one step further
and conducted diary studies.
Diary studies, as the
name already indicates,
are studies where your
user is going to keep
a diary about their usage.
So what did we do?
We sent Voice Access
home with the users
on their personal
devices installed,
and they could use it
in whichever context
they wanted to.
The only thing they
had to do-- they
actually had to promise us--
was that they would report back
about the experience.
So you can do that
over the phone,
you can have them write emails,
or just fill in a quick survey.
And in the end of
the study, they
would come back into
the office with us
and give us a report-- how they
used the product, what they
liked, what they didn't like.
What we learned
from that process
is that for one,
Voice Access really
needs to be polished and
be visually delightful.
You've seen in the video the
latest design that we have.
We didn't start off on that.
I have a few more examples
on that in a minute from you.
And the second thing,
if you use it on the go,
you need a really easy way to
activate and deactivate it.
Because otherwise, it's too
much hassle for the user
to actually dive
into the software
and then again, when you
don't want it to listen,
deactivate it.
So let me show you these
examples that I just mentioned.
The first one that I
would like to talk about
is how we improve
the contextual help.
You see on the left-hand
side the before,
and on the right-hand
side, you see the after.
So what is that?
On the left-hand side, we see
a long list of all the voice
commands that we're offering.
Everyone who's
using or developing
on voice-based software knows
that the biggest challenge
is how can you actually teach
your user what they can say
and how can they remember that.
So it is essential that we
are offering a place where
the user can go
back and check again
what they can say in order
to get to a specific result.
We thought, it makes sense
to just offer one long list,
everything in one place.
People will find that way.
When we observed them
in usability studies,
we found that this is
actually not the case.
People got lost
along the long list.
They even forgot what
they were looking for,
because they were so
overwhelmed by all the stuff
that we offer in there.
And also the way we
presented the information,
without any examples, was
not intuitive to understand
for them.
So what did we do?
We see on the right-hand
side the first screen shot.
We have categories now.
So we have Basics and
navigation, Gestures,
and Text editing.
And with those, the users
deep-dived into a smaller
subset of commands.
What you see then on
the next screenshot,
within Basics and navigation,
that the user actually
gets specific examples
of the voice action
that they can take.
And by doing so, we actually
had much better results
that users were able to
find what they were saying
and also for remembering
later on where
to find that command again.
The second example I'd like to
show to you is our tutorial.
Again, having a
really good tutorial
is crucial, especially
if people have not
used voice interactions
before in order
to navigate the interface.
We wanted to make it
as real as possible,
so we took a screenshot
of the interface
and explained it to the users.
What we didn't
expect was that users
would want to interact
with this screenshot,
and wouldn't distinguish
between a screenshot
versus the real product.
So we took the learning back,
and we designed the experience,
as you see it on
the right-hand side,
to be text explaining
the functionality.
So this is how to use
some numbers, what
Scott had demoed before.
And we did have numbers
now on the screen,
but those are real, so you
can interact with them.
So the user is learning
about it immediately,
and they can apply the learning.
And with that, we actually
made really good progress.
And now Jen is going to
talk about usability testing
and how you can use it for
your very own application.
JEN DEVINS: Thanks, Astrid.
So in the few
minutes remaining, we
wanted to leave you with a
quick starter guide of how
to do your own
usability studies,
because we do find
them very effective.
And you don't need
anything fancy
to actually execute these.
Usability testing
is really useful
to understand how people
use your product and why.
And that's the key
point is the why.
Before you jump and
just bring somebody in
and have them run
through some tests,
you want to have a
plan and a strategy,
first starting with what are
the key questions you want
to answer with this research.
Write these down, review
them with your team,
make sure everyone
is on the same page.
These are your
research questions.
And without solid
research questions,
the end result might not meet
everybody's expectations.
So based on these
questions, then you'll
identify tasks that will help
you answer these questions.
So for example,
if a question was,
are users able to onboard
without any additional
assistance, you would
bring in the new user
and have them start the
app for the first time
and maybe run through some
of your key fundamental tasks
and see if they can
do it without asking
for assistance from you,
looking in the help, or online.
Once you're happy with your
study and your test questions
and tasks, you want
to think about who
to bring in and actually
conduct the study on.
Now, you can certainly start
with friends and family.
Ideally, those people will
actually be using your product,
or do use it.
And we also highly
recommend having
a diverse set of participants
as much as possible.
And you can actually reach
out to various organizations
that lobby for
accessibility needs,
and they're more than willing
to accommodate you and get
some people to help
run the study on.
Now, when it comes to actually
running it and figuring out
where to run this, you
don't need a fancy lab
like we showed.
You can just find a
quiet, comfortable space.
And you want to make sure
that there's room in there
for yourself, the
participant, obviously.
Ideally, you will have
somebody to help take notes,
and you'll have some
video recording equipment.
And also, it's great to have
a developer or a designer,
somebody that's very
close to the product,
there to observe as well.
And there's been
tons of books written
on how to actually conduct
usability studies effectively.
They all kind of boil it down
to these four key steps--
asking the users to
perform the test,
and then taking a step back
and just observing them,
seeing what are they
actually doing other
than completing the task.
Are they hovering in
interesting spots?
Are they using a keyboard?
What keyboard shortcuts
are they using?
And that leads to
the next point,
which is digging into why.
I notice you were
hovering over that button.
Can you tell me why?
What did you expect to happen?
Or after they
complete a task, did
that meet your expectations?
And this is the magic of
usability studies-- being
able to actually understand
the rationale and the meaning
behind their behaviors.
And then I think the most
challenging part of this,
especially if you are
close to the product,
is remaining neutral.
You might have the urge to want
to kind of defend or explain,
well, we tried this,
but we couldn't do this,
or we tried this.
This is not the time to do that.
You're just there to
listen, absorb the feedback,
and move on.
Oh, and then practice.
Definitely practice
at least once
before bringing in real users.
During the study,
you want to ensure
that you write down the most
interesting findings right
away.
And then review those
findings with your team
after each participant.
This will greatly
help at the end,
just kind of summarizing
your findings.
If you have the ability
to actually videotape it,
cut small video snippets to
help support your findings.
Again, not everybody will
have been there with you
during the study, so when
you're presenting your findings,
you can show, look, this
is how the users actually
interacted with the app.
And then one of the
most critical pieces
is it would be a real shame
to do all of this work
and have it just sit in
a dock somewhere unused.
You want to have
somebody in charge,
ready to drive the process
to address these issues.
Of course, it doesn't have to
happen right then and there.
But you want to be sure that
somebody is taking the charge
to prioritize and
figure out what
are bugs, what are
feature requests,
and when they will be addressed.
So we have on the
I/O app in our Spaces
a great link to give
you more details
on how to conduct usability
studies if you're interested.
And overall, we hope
that you've found
that this brief overview of
the research methodologies
used for Voice Access inspiring.
And hopefully you can
bring it back to your team.
And now back to Patrick.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK CLARY: All right.
Thanks, Jen.
Thank you, everyone,
for attending.
So as you can see, it's
very important for us
to hear from users with
accessibility needs
so that we can learn how
to improve the platform
and for all of our developers
to take into account Android
development best
practices, so we can all
make apps that are great
for everyone who has
different accessibility needs.
So if you'd like to try out
Voice Access, it's in beta now.
You can sign up for the
beta at g.co/voiceaccess.
Also listed on the
screen here are
some other talks we're doing
that are accessibility-related.
Please attend those.
They're all great.
Come visit our sandbox.
It's Access & Empathy.
It's actually right
over that way.
And you can go there to
do a demo of Voice Access.
You can go see the demo of
the Sesame head tracking,
learn about many more things,
and also attend our code lab.
So thank you, everyone.
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]